hello everyone today I want to talk to
you about a few important topics and the
first topic is to be or not to be in
other words should I become an expert or
be a generalist when it comes to
bioinformatics the second topic is I
want to talk about your future academic
career I know that a lot of us are
interested in research we might be
looking for opportunities to go to
graduate school postgraduate education
eventually maybe our hopes are to be you
know a funded Pi in a lab or maybe a
teaching Professor so I think that in
these considerations it's important to
think about what are the alternatives to
this kind of an academic path that we
most likely see in our Educators in The
Faculty that we deal with as we are at
the University
also whether the courses lectures
training opportunities
you know workshops that you participate
are they enough or not enough so what is
really a way to develop your own
personal profile with projects that you
have completed experiences that you've
had example work that you can share and
what kinds of event participation is
important for employers when they look
at your resume
then I'll talk a little bit about
growing your community how you can build
a network and what does that networking
really mean here in the space of
bioinformatics you know in any space
networking is important but in
bioinformatics specifically you know who
do you want to be friends with connected
with how do you want to build out that
interaction and then I want to talk a
little bit about
the commonly identified gaps in
somebody's experience so that you can
know how to fill that particular Gap or
how to present the Gap in a positive
light
I also want to talk a little bit about
different types of bioinformatics
positions in all of these fields in
research in Academia in Industry you
will find a variety of positions or role
descriptions that are called
bioinformatics so really some of these
positions are devops or people that have
a computer science background an
engineering background and people are
looking for those kinds of skills to
assist with bioinformatics kind of on
the back end they want to build out
environments that are effective and use
different types of you know
comprehensive resources like high
performance Computing which is very
important in bioinformatics
another type of a position is a
researcher so somebody that actually
asks questions but has enough
engineering skills as well as problem
solving and biology skills to be able to
get to that answer and I'll talk a
little bit more about that
bioinformatician you know when people
are actually looking for a bioinformed
edition what do they mean by that and I
think most of the time they could lean
towards this more of an algorithm
development and methods a person who
knows enough mathematics to be able to
solve complex problems maybe in novel
and different ways so we'll talk a
little bit about how can you develop
relevant skills for each one of these
directions which are actually very
different and you know maybe also talk a
little bit about more you know where
should you start essentially and and how
to leverage some of the skills that or
the talent that you already have to get
further ahead in that particular space
now let me start by first of all
introducing myself my name is Elia
Brodsky I have gone through many online
courses and as a result of this
experience I've actually realized some
things about certification about project
portfolios and about other types of
issues that I think come up when we
speak about gaining that kind of uh you
know experience and background that
people are looking for in careers
so what I realized is that you know a
lot of people visit
um on different websites
take online tutorials maybe watch videos
and they see that as proof that they
know something right and so I think that
when it comes to bioinformatics there is
a kind of a you know difference between
what is a standard right so everybody is
expected to have a certain set of skills
and then what is optional and that
optional component is what I believe
differentiates you from the rest
so that could be your portfolio what you
have on your GitHub profile if you have
some you know coding projects that
you've done analysis projects that you
have done you know that's where people
might put up that notebook that Jupiter
Notebook on your GitHub profile or even
if you develop some kind of a method you
know that could be a place where you can
deposit that
kaggle you know kaggle is really an
opportunity to problem solve come up
with new ideas solve data analysis
challenges better than somebody else
it's really competitive especially
around challenges that they post but
beyond that as well you can actually
build out a portfolio and it's
searchable and you know you can come up
there as well LinkedIn I think is an
important place where skill
credentialing is growing insignificant
so you can actually take LinkedIn
courses or use other coursework to
actually build out your skill set
and apply for jobs at the same time
right so it kind of brings those two
things together and then other things
that I think are really valued in the
academic space obviously but actually
are also valuable in the space of
Industry you know so poster
presentations Publications those are
very important because they really
demonstrate beyond what you can explain
on your GitHub profile or your kaggle
competition or a certificate you can
demonstrate what is it actually that you
have solved and how have you approached
a complex problem with a team
or with a mentor API so really that's
why
we developed this kind of a pathway and
originally we were focused a lot on
Research problems because I think
research is much more difficult than
building out your skills and so what we
did is build out this process from basic
training to more and more advanced
training that especially focuses on
projects around a specialization track
and once you have that project to
provide you with an opportunity to
showcase the result of your project so
let's talk today about how this could be
used in two ways one for a research
fellowship and another one for an
industry internship so for the research
Fellowship we have a research fellowship
program and that program is really
designed around a mentor guided Deep
dive on a particular challenge where you
can propose an independent project with
that kind of feedback from both your
peers and your mentor
getting it further into completion that
is uh showing how you were able to
identify a very specific problem with an
effective solution and demonstrate
evidence that you actually found right
so I think that's especially valuable in
the academic space even though it has
its value in the industry as well but
for industry I think what they are
looking for are different types of
challenges that you could address and
you know that understanding
of the business problem that they're
trying to solve of the specific types of
questions that might be more relevant
for them are very needed and I think
that you know that's where this new
approach for industry uh requires for us
to take a look a little bit deeper at
what kinds of internships or what kind
of positions exist for the industry
itself so on our portal on the Amish
logic portal we recently
started listing out job opportunities
curating them to identify different
types of opportunities more academic
more experience building more internship
in companies and I think that is an
attempt to link it to the ranking system
that we have where in the ranking we
actually have the top experts that are
the most
it's all right
that are the most accomplished
in terms of how much experience they've
actually gained so let's talk a little
bit about some of these examples
so let's look at these you know I think
a common uh problem that people have is
when you look at a student's resume they
don't have enough experience so here we
have a category of jobs called
experience building and different
companies you can see somewhere in India
some are in U.S somewhere in Dubai and
you can visit this page to kind of see
opportunities around the world really
for bioinformatics so it shows us that
bioinformatics positions are in demand
now let's look at what kind of
information you can find here and let's
talk a little bit more about this so
here's an example of skill requirements
and other requirements right and so
these are typically hard skills like you
can see Proficiency in Python Pearl or R
so one of these three languages
proficiency working in a Linux
environment and with Unix shell
scripting familiarity with the standard
bioinformatics tools and databases right
so these are kind of your hard skills
and then more of the soft skills is
should have research and working
experience in bioinformatics should be
able to analyze and interpret the data
in a biological context identify and or
conceive novel data science approaches
to better and more efficiently analyze
client and public data sets right so
these are important data sets to think
about or sorry skills to think about as
you are considering am I ready for this
opportunity now this specifically is for
master's degree students maybe that have
completed their master's degree and
they're quite technical let's look at
another job
this opportunity is for undergraduate
students so you can see that they have a
bachelor's degree or equivalent so you
don't even need to have a full
bachelor's degree in bioinformatics
computational biology computer science
or related field and what is important
five years related experience
working with cytogenics data
Etc so let's try to kind of organize
some of this information and then we'll
see what does it actually tells us so
minimum bachelor's degree is not in
bioinformatics necessarily but a
bachelor's degree plus five years of
experience you have to understand
pipelines R Python and SQL communication
tutorials and documentation Cloud
development Google Cloud platform or AWS
database experience experience with
commonly used tools and packages and
prior research experience let's organize
these points and talk about what
categories of skills do we have here
so first of all you have something that
you know we cannot reproduce elsewhere a
university can only give you that uh
bachelor's degree but then there's the
five years experience piece as well
so this tells you that a lot of these
job opportunities require that track
record of experience so it's not enough
to start you know today and three months
later bam you've got a job no you need
to have some years of experience
demonstratable on your resume
uh the second uh kind of section here
the green one are the technical skills
so pipelines are python SQL Cloud
development database experience
experience with tools and packages
that's where certification is very
important so you should get a
certificate in building pipelines in r
in Python in SQL in Cloud development
Etc and that is what the omics logic
portal can help you with is getting
those certificates
the last part of this are soft skills
communication where you can develop
tutorials and documentation and we
actually provide opportunities like that
in our internship program here at Pine
biotech and prior research experience
where really those research projects
demonstrate your research experience as
well
so let's talk about the first one the
first one is skills you can really only
show that you have a particular skill by
showing your certificate now I want to
highlight here this example which is a
person who is a clinical biochemist he
is on LinkedIn and active on LinkedIn
but also active on our portal and he
regularly posts his certificates for
example here he completed the r coding
course introduction to data science or
bioml course right so this kind of a
certificate linked to your LinkedIn
profile link to your maybe career
aspirations is critical and I I think
this is a great example of demonstrating
what kind of skills do you have
here's another example and this is one
of our interns as SRI gowri Krishna
Kumar who has developed a series of uh
tutorials on a particular course on the
transcriptomics course
which really shows that she has the
capacity for communication for being
able to edit texts develop tutorials
develop documentation present that
tutorial right that's a very critical
skill that a lot of companies are
looking for
and finally prior research experience so
I think a starting point for this prior
research experience is having a project
that you have started but the project on
the Onyx logic portal is something that
you begin with but then you get to
complete it and a lot of people go
through several stages so for example
here we have one of our research fellows
rivaja who has completed a project
presented it several times and
eventually published this in June 2022
in this journal immunogenetics and she
was actually
um
uh she was actually uh you know posting
that as well so I think that's a great
contribution uh to her uh ability to
show prior research experience
so finally how do we organize all of
this information on our resume so I
think as anyone who is completing their
degree or thinking about their next
steps in the career you want to now take
all of this information and build it
into a story that reflects your skills
your experience the projects that you
have worked on and those soft skills
that you want to speak about so here you
have an example of a traditional resume
on your left where you're looking at
your you know typical employment history
education honor mentions and things like
that and it's visually Pleasant to kind
of see this kind of a resume
but here's another
um uh resume that I just recently came
across as we were hiring interns
where um instead of just speaking about
uh you know what this person has done in
terms of completing a degree and you
know going to different jobs this person
specifically is a high school student
right so so really
um somebody that's just going to finish
High School
um and uh you know will kind of start
their career but already is
participating in a bunch of different
projects and experiences that he is
involved in so I think that this really
shows how the nature of this resume is
changing you can start adding
experiences like an internship a project
that you've worked on some contribution
that you made to somebody else's startup
as a way to build out that lengthy
experience that people are looking for
so with that I'm going to wrap it up
we do invite you to contact our team
about help identifying those
opportunities for you to advance your
career help you identify opportunities
to build out those lacking elements in
your resume with appropriate skills with
appropriate project examples and
experiences that we can help link you to
and finally build out your network so
here I do want to invite you all to join
both our portal which is a network of
over 20 000 students from around the
world and our groups we have a group on
Facebook we have a group on LinkedIn has
a lot of diverse talents positions
experts director level and below that
you can start connecting with and
importantly share your achievements
share about your certificates that
you're earning share the projects that
you are completing and share your
presentations if you are able to present
well people will spot that they want
people who know how to communicate so
thank you again for taking the time to
listen to this presentation and I hope
to see you in our next webinar